I don't know why you're Asian mark Wow
that's how we're gonna start off this
episode huh
[Music]
you should just go directly to that
black screen you're Asian mark maybe
maybe hi
where does this [ __ ] traffic didn't
we just spend half an hour trying to
figure out the signs to make my work
here cars
no this isn't Grantham town Oh ride a
car oh he's good he's good
let's go car well at least he's using
his turn signal did your arms up
majestically can I like Skitch on the
cars whoa yeah green like [ __ ] out of
here I want to say that there is a way
to like yeah you don't like this now I'm
on you like it skateboarding scoffs Rank
whoa what the hell okay so this is not a
traffic simulator I well that's gonna
say yes we haven't mentioned that this
is a Isaac Clark skateboarding oh yeah
yeah oh and hi everybody
we're playing skate three with Isaac
Clark oh oh oh I haven't done them for
Santa Claus oh oh he danced me hey hey
hey hey hey hey dude dude man ladies uh
kid hey oh all right fighting he's
getting it on he's getting mad he's get
always through his coffees mad now
playtime [ __ ] go up whoa oh god what
happened
[Laughter]
no yeah here I'm not done with you oh I
don't even remember how they did that
die oh my god oh wow you're like life
oh come back Frank be my friend be my
only one and only friend so fast yes but
only a short burst only when he wants it
let me go what you all right buddy [ __ ]
Oh needs eval and need some water good
[Laughter]
do your Isaac Clark should be really
disturbing oh my god he's dead oh well
head-butted me in the nuts you can get
him with that I would be very impressed
all right now stay down yeah no much
that woman is checking you out
what do you want lady what do you want I
have the force I think she has it and
I'll punch you good job sports you did
some good work today
good hustle out there yeah good good
teamwork like the cutter Joe hey Jim I'm
gonna congratulate you by tender loving
embrace like this oh she's making a
break for it
oh she's walking all sassy lady lady
lady lady lady lady don't don't run even
though you're not even out in a hurry
but don't run away from us just look I'm
playing guitar it's awesome lady just
chill just chill just chill just chill
just lady
wait just chill lady just chill lady
just can we talk can we talk it out she
can't run in heels your waiting room can
we talk about this kid watch Jesus
you're so strong I'm I'm Isaac Larkin
here
can we just talk about this okay all
right sees no interest until you let me
have a crack at her
that's not a way you can win her over go
back here are you well that just freaked
her out even more no no no no no lady
she's not even walking on sidewalk she's
displaying oh where can I go where you
don't follow me where'd you go there's a
very interesting she there she is hi
let's be friend mark hi friend no hang
on hang on come back here oh you feel
threatened about me
what's wrong oh all right she's stepping
you're a she's dead I love you let me so
let us talk about our embrace this mask
won't separate us please you're so bad
she can't stay off you man
oh whoa Jesus she's like wasted and lady
no minutes we've been like jumping on
this finally she was like all right if
you jump on me 13 all right she's down
get her I'm getting to it lady lady [ __ ]
what's Wow no no no lady lady lady lady
please maybe if you talk like guys it's
like she'll Bolivia Isaac Clark I just
want everyone not to forget what just
happened with the eyes of Clark boys
okay really I'm I'm Isaac Clark hey I'm
so angry and I'm a space miner engineer
I forget what else happens in my video
game though
well there were zombies and aliens and
zombie aliens and all sorts
stuff happened hello lady excuse me wow
this is it's fine now no it is not fine
accelerate so you don't happy oh that's
what I've been doing wrong do we go to
the movies Oh falling down fetal
position
whoa a place for that hold it down
goddamn stairs won't let me go anywhere
grinding oh I was pressing squirrel damn
idiot shut up I'm just I've tried my
best here now my foots you landed on all
your toes thank you you're wearing a
frickin suit of armor you would think so
if you can get like three of them
ganging up one's an owl clobber no gonna
get me now oh we're gonna know what's
the carpet Ron whoa
it's almost [ __ ] up Santa scores ever
been man no man I was through up OK's
accident please do not on camera sorry
I think about that thing I sent you if
anyone gets the show that I just
referenced
you're cool yeah I can't remember
exactly oh well that doesn't count
yeah dude bro I got your reference what
was it this was thinking I just I was
like man I don't see there's that or
it's the sequel that they made that was
like yeah yeah exactly
ooh dunk something in the basketball
hoop how in the ass ramp in front oh
you're right you're right you're right
you're right you're never dunk yourself
through the basketball whoo I'm in the
wrong country
Oh God god damn I do ki raat triangle is
the green one did you learn your shapes
when I'm alright just time a PC game
just to bring everything full circle
yeah I was referencing Harvey Birdman
attorney at law
oh yeah that he works with
Horton Lee ever talks about this amazing
for some reason I was thinking like yeah
I was like I Spit off it was like
related yeah no that's I believe you
so what you should do then is go off the
ramp push triangle and then push our of
to and try and jump your skateboard in
the hoop is that what we've decided Oh
hope it's all those instructions again
so make sure you what does it makes all
those arches the ramp once you jump the
triangle and then hit R 2 and perfect
[ __ ] how and that's really good
that's Oh fancy skateboarding are you
dude get out of the way we're doing
something I'll start on top of that
thing er you hold X Martin
[ __ ] goddamn it piece of [ __ ] ass so
just so sprint at it hit triangle and
then hold hold X legs and then jump
that's pretty close except that you
completely missed I I was because you
know as a cop Laverne thank you think a
burn iment since doesn't tell you what
it was at all that was a burn scooter
she floor I made that word up so means
right
oh that was kinda it's pretty close got
it all right moving on dunk your brain
in the best
[Music]